ich bin fast täglich in schulen bestehe
die entwicklungen ich arbeite mit lehrer
und lehrerinnen und ich kann eins sagen
unser schulsystem ist veraltet auch die
korona privat sehr deutlich gezeigt
diese schulsystem muss erneuert werden
wie muss reformiert werden sie muss
zukunftsfähig werden dann schüler und
schülerinnen die heute in der schule
sind müssen nicht nur leistung erbringen
sondern das ist unsere chance diese
menschen zu erreichen ihn das auf dem
weg zu geben schule ist eine
sozialisation sword und nicht nur ort
des lernens wir müssen neuer fescher wir
müssen zukunftsorientiert wir müssen
endlich verstehen dass wir in eine
vielfältige gesellschaft leben wo die
herausforderungen die auf uns zukommen
anders sind wir brauchen nicht nur mathe
und endlich die natürlich wichtig sind
wir brauchen robotiker wir brauchen
programmierer wir brauchen
medienkompetenz wir brauchen demokratie
forderung wir brauchen debattieren wie
brauchen lehrer und lehrerinnen die in
der lage auch diese generation zu
verstehen und wir sind weit weg entfernt
und jedes mal gibt eine debatte nacht
nach irgend welche missstände die klar
werden oder deutlich werden aber es
passiert nicht wir brauchen jetzt ein
thema die übrige ist politisch platziert
werden muss um unsere schule
zukunftsfähig zu machen und das nicht
ganz gut gefallen hat war dass du auch
themen anspricht lieben medienerziehung
demokratie vermittlung und damit inhalte
was nicht so sehr stört auch in den
letzten monaten auch schon letzten jahr
es wird immer gerufen die schulen
brauchen digitalisierung whiteboards
laptops und dann denke ich mir meine
jahr wenn der lehrer extrem gut ist dann
kann man auch an den normalen tafel noch
arbeiten zum beispiel haares verzichten
sogar auf whiteboards und bleiben beim
papier also sagen papier bildet papier
ist gut und auch normalen handel in
hengen haare oder so naja sagen wir mal
so am geld scheitert es nicht inhaber
dass die whiteboards sich hinstellen und
da sind kann ich es gerade so wichtig
endlich meinen diskurs nicht immer
whiteboards laptops und ipads und das
denkmal medienverständnis in demokratien
wisst ihr was jack ma sagte jack ma ist
ja der ist ja von ali baba ist der
wichtigsten internet technik im
milliardäre der welt der sagt bringt den
kindern auf der schule nicht zu viele
edv und zuviel robotik ich weiß nicht
was bei
das können die maschinen bald selber
sich programmieren und und weiterlernen
die leute kinder sollen gedichte lernen
sie sollen die große literatur lernen
sollen die symphonische musik
kennenlernen denn das sind dinge die
nicht von maschinen lernen können und
wir auch menschen können werden ich
glaube schon dass wir ja die zukunfts
fischer schon vermitteln müssen aber ich
gebe dir und auch die anderen recht ist
muss eine schule sein die unsere kindern
fordert die unsere kinder die
möglichkeit gibt sich auf das leben
vorbereiten die in der lage sind in eine
zukunftsorientierte gesellschaft sich
zurechtzufinden und erfolgreich zu sein
mittlerweile muss man sagen erfolgreich
sein zu wollen ist schon eine sünde in
manchen greifen aber ich finde ich es
wichtig das muss auch leistung dabei
sein aber bis zum koma um auf dich nie
dazu kommen bis zum corona krise haben
viele gedacht digitalisierung bedeutet
wlan zu installieren eine schule
digitalisierung ist vielmehr
digitalisierungs die möglichkeit die
kinder
unterschiedlicher inhalte zu vermitteln
vielleicht digital auch mit
medienkompetenz umzugehen wie sehen ja
mobbing situationen im sozialen medien
tätig wie sehen ja wie sehen das die
kinder nicht wirklich wissen wie sie mit
ihren daten umgehen da sind alle inhalte
die enorm wichtig sind aber sie sind in
die schule von heute gar nicht vorhanden
ich sage mir als vater zweier töchter in
berlin kann ich dir nur zustimmen weil
ich glaube das wird wirklich nicht vor
dem tor stand sondern für die berliner
noch gute schon was wirklich wichtig
wäre
finde ich ist dass die die kinder lernen
zu denken und diese ganzen
technologischen dinge also die die die
werden sich ja ändern also das was ich
im fach computer science für das stimmt
einigen jahrzehnten gelernt habt ist ist
heute nicht mehr anwendbar gab es ja
damals nicht verstanden aber
wie dem auch sei glaub ich ist es ist
sehr wichtig in dieser bildungs kultur
dass die kinder wirklich herausgefordert
werden und zu denken und das fängt bei
den lehrern anja also man muss den beruf
lehrer
schmackhaft machen die ausbildung von
lehrern lernen sollte ganz anders
gestalten werden genau und es muss sich
auch lohnen also die müssen mehr
verdienen und das geld fehlt offenbar
weil nach dem was ich jetzt gehört hat
in berlin also werden die mittel für für
schulen weiterhin gestrichen würdest du
dir wünschen
präsentieren und debattieren genauso sie
sind so zwei sachen die wir immer mehr
brauchen werden ich bin ich sage alles
andere können wir googeln aber ist
natürlich ist rechtschreibung wichtig
gedichte lernen ist sicherlich auch
etwas schönes und zu abstrahieren aber
das sind so dinge die zu interagieren
miteinander zu arbeiten auch ohne diese
klassischen gruppenarbeit wieder
aufleben zu lassen aber filmprojekt wo
man gemeinschaftlich etwas macht dass
wir nicht gut ich habe jetzt gerade
heute von einer bekannten ganz unfall
aus gehört aus sperrholz bayern was
davon gesprochen wlan gibt es eine
elterninitiative das wlan abzuschalten
weil sie sagen dass verstrahlte unsere
kinder also auch in der schule auch so
ist also ob damit muss man sich
auseinandersetzen oder auch als lehrer
insofern ist eben gar kein gar kein ende
märz gesetzt was man was man alles
denken muss aber ich denke dieses
präsentieren debattieren und wenn ich
wir haben ja die bilder gesehen von den
schulen also das sieht ja immer noch so
aus überall oder vielfach wie vor 20.30
uhr sind nicht schlimm wenn die lehrer
kurzen bilder wirklich ich muss es
wirklich immer ich sag es so offen
nein aber ich finde zum beispiel tanja
ich meine eine harvard business school
die haben ja geld wie heu das ist ja
eine der besten sitzen wenn ich die
besten vernetzte universität der welt
dass man sich nach dem ob sogar die ist
die haben auch normale tafeln dort auch
hängen schilder kann man auch schöner
kann man auch ohne whiteboard
lehrer hat und die wirklich was wollen
ich glaube da kann man auch in der tafel
noch die sachen auf schreiben also ich
finde wir hängen uns immer so an dem der
ausstattung ab hat aber zu wenig an den
in australien konnte sich jede neue idee
nicht mein bruder hat sich das etabliert
als
unterrichtsform des jahrhunderts oder
gibt es vielleicht nicht andere ideen
wie man miteinander entschuldigungen man
kann auch das flexibel gestalten je nach
kind der klasse man kann auch anders
setzt ordnung wir brauchen natürlich
auch ausstattung aber das thema nummer
eins für die zukunft ist kritisches
denken ist die kinder zu befähigen ihre
eigene meinung zu bilden vor allem in
eine digitale zeitalter und ich
befürchte wenn das nicht passiert dann
ist unsere gesamte demokratie in gefahr
tut mir leid dass ich so deutlich sagen
aber kritisches denken ist das a und o
für eine gesunde mitte die wir in diese
gesellschaft brauchen wenn man twitter
und sozialen medien anschaut und vor
allem für jugendliche vor was
jugendlicher mittlerweile sich
begeistern dann muss ich sagen wir die
schule muster ihre aufgabe ernst nehmen
und versuchen diese jugendlicher
demokratie und kritische standby zu
binden ich finde das schon mal es war
fast schon wieder schluss oder aber eine
runde haben wir noch jeder sagt einfach
kurz und bündig was er gerne hätte wir
starten bei dir ich hätte gern mehr
geschichte wie wir heute erlebt mehr
geschichte ist gut ich hätte gern
mathematik ist in vielen ländern ein
top-produkt hätte fast gesagt ein top
was auch toll vermittelt wird wir
schreiten irgendwie da dran und wir
reden es unschön nicht gut sein zu sein
in mathe ich hätte gern mehr mathe ich
bereue am meisten m der sich physik nie
gelernt habe ich finde das unglaublich
schade dass ich würde mir wünschen für
die schulen in deutschland richtig guten
physikunterricht der lust darauf macht
das zu verstehen weil das ist mein manko
gibt keine physik kenntnisse ja ich
stehe dazu ich bin für bessere debattier
klassen debattierclubs da hätte ich auch
sehr viel davon profitieren können
nachhinein
debattierclubs über aktuelle politische
themen